Bonjour à toutes et à tous !
Haaa c'est la saison des pique-niques.
Et on redécouvre le plaisir de partager son petit repas de plein air
avec des invitées bourdonnantes.
Mais que se passe-t-il dans la tête de
ces petites abeilles,
paisibles ouvrières,
pour qu'elles se transforment aussi vite en des kamikazes déterminés,
prêtes à mourir pour défendre leur ruche.
BANZAÏ !!!
(JINGLE)
Plusieurs études ont montré que la défense de la ruche est collective.
Lorsque les abeilles détectent
une menace,
elles produisent un ensemble de molécules,
qu'on appelle phéromones d'alarme,
pour prévenir les autres membres de la colonie.
Leurs congénères ainsi alertées
sortent de la ruche à la recherche de l'ennemi potentiel
et se joignent à l'attaque.
Un peu comme nos armées, sauf que l'alerte n'est pas envoyée par radio mais par phéromones.
Des chercheurs du Centre de cognition
animale de Toulouse
ont voulu comprendre ce qu'il se passe dans le cerveau des abeilles
pour déclencher une telle agressivité à l'arrivée de la phéromone.
Pour cela, ils sont allés chercher des abeilles dans des ruches
en utilisant une plume pour les faire sortir.
Cette méthode garantit que les
abeilles récupérées
sont bien des gardiennes défendant la ruche.
Et surtout qu'elles ne meurent pas en piquant le leurre.
"Peeeetit petit petit petit petit petit petit"
Avec ces petites abeilles,
ils ont réalisé une expérience
pour tester leur comportement face à une menace
en présence et en l'absence de
phéromones d'alarme.
Par paire, les abeilles gardiennes sont
envoyées dans une petite arène circulaire
dans laquelle un leurre noir tourne et
les gène.
Les chercheurs observent alors la fréquence à laquelle les abeilles piquent.
Oui, un petit boudin avec une plume,
ça paraît pas une grande menace.
Mais du point de vue des abeilles,
il faut vous imaginer face à un immense taureau mécanique à plumes
qui tourne sur lui même pour vous mettre des grosses baffes !
Bam !
Ca vous donne pas envie de piquer vous ?!
En l'absence de phéromones d'alarme,
certaines abeilles piquent et d'autres se
contentent d'éviter l'obstacle.
La même expérience est réalisée en présence de phéromones.
Et là sans surprise,
les abeilles attaquent plus rapidement et
piquent à une fréquence plus élevée.
A partir des résultats de ces expériences,
ils ont classé les abeilles :
les abeilles paisibles qui ne piquent pas le leurre
et les abeilles agressives qui l'attaquent.
Les abeilles OKLM d'un côté.
Les abeilles vénères de l'autre.
Mais les chercheurs sont allés plus loin.
Dans chaque cas, ils ont analysé le cerveau des abeilles,
et mesuré la quantité de trois molécules stars
chez les spécialistes du comportement.
la dopamine, la sérotonine et l'octopamine.
Ces molécules agissent sur les neurones
et la transmission des informations dans le cerveau.
Ce sont des neurotransmetteurs,
des neuromodulateurs
et des neurohormones.
Mais elles sont surtout connues pour réguler l'agressivité
chez de nombreuses espèces
d'insectes et de mammifères
chez nous aussi..
GRRRRRRR !
Les chercheurs ont observé
que le cerveau des abeilles agressives était bourré de sérotonine.
Et ils ont aussi constaté
que l'exposition à la phéromone d'alarme
augmentait les taux de dopamine et de sérotonine
dans le cerveau de toutes les abeilles.
Pour montrer que ces molécules sont bien responsables
de l'agressivité des abeilles,
les chercheurs ont recommencé leurs expériences.
Mais cette fois-ci, les
cobayes sont préalablement tartinés
soit avec de la dopamine,
soit avec de la sérotonine,
soit avec des produits
qui empêchent ces molécules d'agir.
et là Bim !
Le constat est sans appel.
Les abeilles les plus shootées à la sérotonine ou à la dopamine
sont celles qui piquent le plus.
Et à l'inverse,
celles qui ne ressentent plus les effets de ces molécules, ne piquent plus.
Ces expériences démontrent donc
que c'est en augmentant la quantité
de sérotonine et de dopamine dans le cerveau
que la phéromone d'alarme
provoque le changement de comportement de l'abeille.
et cette quantité peut varier
d'un individu à l'autre,
en présence ou pas d'une phéromone d'alarme.
Mais aussi en fonction de l'âge de l'abeille,
du patrimoine génétique de la ruche
et qui sait, peut-être, même de la météo.
Ainsi, la diffusion de la phéromone d'alarme
n'envoie pas directement un signal d'attaque
mais augmente la probabilité
que d'autres abeilles osent se transformer en kamikaze.
Etrangement,
l'abeille est un animal que l'humain a domestiqué depuis la préhistoire.
Et pourtant, on est loin de comprendre
toutes les facettes de son comportement.
En étudiant les systèmes de défense de l'abeille,
ces recherches pourraient offrir
de nouvelles possibilités de gestion de son agressivité,
pour améliorer les
conditions de travail des apiculteurs par exemple
ou pour compenser l'impact
des pesticides sur leurs comportements.
Voilà ! J'espère que cette recherche va
faire le buzzz.
et qu'elle a piqué votre curiosité.
En tout cas,
moi ça me fout toujours
un peu le bourdon de vous quitter,
alors je vous dis au prochain épisode !
Petite mais espiègle Mayaaa
Mais sinon ... ça veut dire quoi OKLM ?
Ben ! Détendu du dard, quoi.
Abonnez-vous !